[Music]
so we live in an increasingly tribal
world and we and there are many who are
fearful of this tribalism thinking that
it means that those who shout loudest
and longest are going to win and I'm
very much in tune with that it seems to
me that a tribal world is genuinely a
frightening one in which those who
happen to be on the side of the tribal
majority are able to impose what they
wish on everyone else and in which we
might become increasingly attached to
our tribes and for ever more into
fighting each other so I'm very much on
the side of thinking that this tribal
world is a worrying one but I am NOT in
any way tempted to think that I should
reach or we should reach for truth as a
solution to this problem and that's
because it seems to me that the history
of the 20th century has been the history
of seeing a retreat from the idea of
truth with a capital T that objective
truth that thing that is somehow
independently there and outside of us
and that's because we become
increasingly aware of the importance of
our perspective that might be a
linguistic perspective it could be a
cultural perspective it could be a
temporal perspective
it could be just that were human but we
become ever more aware of the
perspective or character of our
knowledge and with that the idea that
then we might find some ultimate
position which could see how things
ultimately were seems to be ever more
implausible in fact it seems to me the
idea of philosophical realism is
effectively dead it's over there isn't a
way back to it so the question is what
do we do about that well I think one of
the first things is to see language and
our theories about the world not as
scription x' of how the world is but as
tools to be able to intervene in the
world what we do with our theories is to
create ways to hold the world which
enable us to intervene successfully and
in the same way as if we have a I know
any any tool say a mousetrap and there
are better and worse mousetraps but
there isn't a true one is there and so
it seems to me it is with language and
our accounts of the world it's just a
mistake to imagine that they might be
true now at the moment socially I think
we're at the situation where we're
potentially of having the worst of all
worlds that is on the one hand we have
increasingly come to accept alternative
perspectives and encourage the idea of
different perspectives but we're still
somehow attached to this religious
almost religious belief in truth and the
real and just as some people have given
up on the idea of God as a human fiction
I think we've got to give up on the
notion of the real and true as a human
fiction as well but that doesn't mean to
say that we can just let anything go I
think we have to redouble our attachment
to the rational and to observation in
order to improve our tools in order to
improve our ways of holding the world
and just a last thought at this stage
for those of you who are feeling just a
little disappointed that we might have
to give up on this idea of the real and
the true I mean that is of course what
are those who in the medieval period
wanted to hold to a notion of God and
have indeed more recently they felt they
were losing something by giving up this
fiction
and in the same way many of you may feel
well I don't want to give up on the idea
of the real it somehow makes sense of
what I'm up to but I'd like just to re
set of situate that for you instead of
thinking that you're giving up on the
idea that there's something out there
which you're never going to get to
anyway and people have always disagreed
about and you can't get there think of
the world as being open and what you do
and what we do is we close the world
with our metaphors we close it to make
sense of it and there's no limit to the
number of ways we can close it there's
no limit to the ways in which we can
intervene to hopefully make the world a
better place and we can make those tools
that we create in order to intervene
better by those traditional
enlightenment methods of reason and
observation for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you